this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for years
for all sorts of graphic design needs
whether you need a logo website book
cover anything else 99designs was
created to make great designs accessible
to everyone and to make the process of
getting designs much much easier so when
I first started out for instance
testing prototype covers and getting
prototype covers for the 4-hour body
I want the contest route that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something late-night quick
turnaround well people in other time
zones other countries can also help you
solve that problem since then I've
worked with 99 designs on a separate
path or a different option and that is
the one to one project service so in a
number of cases and I'll give you one
example when I wanted to create the
cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate and provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
some incredibly good really some of the
best illustrations I've ever seen
from using this one-to-one project
service with a handful of different
designers and illustrators it blew my
mind 99 designs makes this all very easy
and efficient so you can check out the
Tao of Seneca design and other work that
I and your fellow listeners for that
matter have done on 99 designs at 99
designs dot-com forward slash Tim again
that's 99 designs dot-com forward slash
Tim
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I have used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you will thank me there are
a few different versions
I like the version that Neal narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time
the second book is vagabonding by Rolf
Potts P o T TS which had a huge impact
on my life and form the basis for a lot
of what would later become the 4-hour
workweek so go to audible.com for word
slash Tim and you can choose one of
these two books or any of many many
other options that could be books
magazines and much more as a listener of
the Tim Ferriss show you can also access
a free 30-day trial just go to
audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at audible.com forward slash
Tim to start now and get your free
30-day trial
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers of
all different types across every
possible discipline to tease out the
details that you can use and apply to
your own life this episode we have a
scientist who is also incredibly good at
teaching dr. Martin Kabbalah
or Martin Kabbalah PhD is a professor
and chair of the kinesiology department
atma caster not Makassar that sounds
like a fish sandwich McMaster University
in Hamilton Ontario his research on the
physiological and health benefits of
high-intensity interval training or hit
has attracted incredible scientific
attention and worldwide media coverage
if you recognize the name there are many
reasons you might because he's published
more than 100 peer-reviewed articles he
has been featured by the New York Times
Wall Street Journal he also appeared
seven years ago in the 4-hour body
because I followed his research and
found it fascinating he is frequently
invited to speak at international
scientific meetings and has received
multiple awards for Teaching Excellence
the reasons for which I think will
become incredibly clear as you listen to
this episode he is the co-author of the
brand-new book the one minute workout
and that may sound ridiculous but by the
end of this episode you will not think
it's ridiculous you will think that it
is entirely scientifically supported and
we dig into some exact protocols that
you can test yourself to take this for a
test drive
so please enjoy my conversation with
Marty Gabala and we do get into the
weeds so if you're having trouble
grasping something bear with us for 30
seconds and we will come out the other
side and end up somewhere else that is
perhaps more easily digested but it is a
fun conversation I had a blast and it is
extremely applicable and practical so
please enjoy
Marty welcome to the show thanks Tim we
were chatting very briefly via Skype
video just a few moments ago and it was
really nice to pair a face with the name
because I have wondered a who is this
guy and because I've read your name so
many times and written your name in the
4-hour body among other places what does
he look like and then be how does he
pronounce his last name we have
addressed both of those this morning and
I'm very happy about that where are you
sitting just to place some context for
people sure I'm at my desk in my office
at McMaster University in Hamilton
Canada and again we were chatting
offline there's been a water main break
out front so in Fahrenheit it's about 50
degrees in my office today which is
which is pretty chilly well you know
cold exposures all the rage these days
although I suppose if you're in in
Canada it gets old pretty quick
which department are you part of I'm in
a Department of kinesiology in a faculty
of science and could you just explain
for people who may not know what falls
under the purview of physiology or what
what is physiology yeah sure physiology
is basically how the body works so how
the system's act in an integrative
manner and so one of the fascinating
things about exercise is it stresses the
body and unique in different ways and so
it makes it a really for me an
interesting topic to study so I this
morning before I spoke with you I teach
a fourth-year course called the
integrative physiology of human
performance and so in that course we
talked about how the body's systems come
together to meet the demand of exercise
so the cardiovascular system the the
muscle system and for me that's what
makes it a really interesting topic in
that class since you brought it up what
do students find most exciting or
fascinating as part of that curriculum
and what do they find most
counterintuitive or difficult
I think a lot of the one of the main
things they like is what regulates the
performance of elite athletes or simply
put what makes elite athletes great and
so a lot of students who come into
kinesiology not all of them but a lot
have a background in exercise they're
interested in sport and so what I try to
do in that course is if you will trick
them a little bit or cajole them into
learning a bit more about how the body's
regulated so we talk a little
biochemistry we talk a little physiology
so that they have a really good
understanding of how the body works and
we often present that using elite
athletes as an example because it's a
prism that can often ground them you
know another thing that I'll try to do
in that class is all of the students
have to perform a vo2 max test on each
other and they have to feel what it is
like to do a vo2 max test so when we
talk about an athlete pushing out a
thousand watts for example or 1500 watts
or holding 400 watts as a pace on a bike
they know what it's like to either come
close to that for a couple of seconds
and I think it really helps to put it in
context a little bit and but bottom line
is they have an appreciation for elite
athletes and then we talk about the
underlying physiology so if I have a few
questions related to the first is a
definition question just for people
listening because I think it'll come up
a few times can you define vo2 Max and
then can you can you tell people if it
is malleable and if so how malleable or
improvable it is sure
so vo2 max or maximal oxygen uptake also
known as maximal aerobic capacity is the
highest rate at which the body can take
up and use oxygen that's typically
during heavy exercise so how we would
test it of have an individual do
progressively higher workloads that
could be on a bike that could be on a
treadmill and at some point your body is
gonna reach its maximal capacity to use
oxygen that's important if you're an
athlete but it's equally important for
health
and so when people talk about cardio
fitness what you're really talking about
is is your vo2 max and it it reflects
the underlying ability of the
cardiovascular system the respiratory
system so your heart your lungs your
blood vessels to deliver oxygen to
working muscles and the ability of the
muscles to use that oxygen to produce
energy so literally to burn fats and
carbohydrates to produce fuel so we say
it's if you're gonna be an elite
endurance athlete high vo2 max is
necessary but not sufficient for success
because obviously there's lots of other
factors involved but it the underlying
physiology is the same and so it's also
a really important parameter for your
health and is it something is it a fixed
metric the way people might think of
height or is it something that can be
improved or meaningfully improved no
it's definitely something that can be
meaningfully improved you know again we
talked about this in my class if if you
want to be an elite endurance athlete
and we hear the phrase pick your parents
properly and that's because you know in
some ways it's it's a bit like a
mortgage there's a there's a fixed
element and there's a variable element
and so the fixed element is determined
by things like the genetic capacity for
your heart size for example but there's
definitely a highly variable element and
we know that because it can respond to
training as well as D training so you
know what typical or average person if
they do traditional endurance training
for a couple of months they might be
able to boost their vo2 max by 20% but
it's a highly individual value or
parameter as well and we know some
people their value doesn't change very
much even though they do highly
structured training whereas other people
they can change it by up to a hundred
percent you know people would be
familiar with the term hardgainers there
there's some hard gainers when it comes
to vo2 max as well but fortunately it's
a relatively small percentage and to
answer your question it's highly
malleable in most individuals I was
chatting with
Peter Diamandis not too long ago a
friend of mine he's the chairman of the
XPrize and involved in many different
companies and he is very good friends
with Ray Kurzweil they co-founded single
singularity University together which is
I think it is still hosted at the NASA
Ames Center in Mountain View California
and he I remember he mentioned to me at
one point that at least two things but
two that that has really jumped out of
the data that correlated to longevity or
maximum lifespan were flossing and high
vo2 max and he said I'll be the first
person to admit that I think flossing
might be correlation and not causation
it could be that people who are anal
retentive enough and disciplined enough
to floss on a daily basis also are
disciplined enough to do other things on
a daily basis to contribute on the vo2
max point do you if you had to speculate
or maybe you don't have to speculate do
you think that that is causative or
correlative with the high vo2 max and
extended lifespan
I think it's causative for sure and
there's a lot of data out there I think
that would support that obviously it's
it's tough to do a proper randomized
clinical trial to look something to
death with humans yeah hard to get the
the IRB approval for that but what we
know if you look at for example
mortality risk of risk of dying from all
causes if individuals there's a concept
called a met or a metabolic equivalent
which I'm sure you're familiar with some
of your your listeners may be familiar
with that but it's essentially a unit of
measurement for vo2 max and individuals
who have a higher a1 met higher value
that translates into about a 13% lower
risk of dying from all causes
obviously that's correlational data but
it's based on fairly strong
epidemiological evidence you might also
be familiar just a couple of weeks ago
there was a paper in JAMA which was
calling for vo2 max or fitness cardio
spirit or fitness to be a vital sign so
it's something that we should measure in
the doctor's office just
like we measure weight and height and
things like blood sugar the problem of
course is that it's it takes some time
to properly measure vo2 max accurately
and obviously that's not feasible in a
lot of physicians offices but there are
now some very good online calculators
that can give individuals a sense of
what their value is how how do they
approximate that online I'm very curious
I've never taken one of these my myself
I have had the great joy of having the
garden hose stuck in my mouth and my
nose clips while I run on a treadmill I
have done that before but I can see why
a lot of doctors offices would not be
super keen to have that as part of their
11 minutes with their patient I how do
they how do they try to infer vo2 max
from from online inputs yeah I've just
seen this recently and actually you know
put my own data in to see how well or
how accurate I thought it was and it was
reasonable it asked things like your age
your sex your things like that some
activities on or your type of activity
that you eventually do and it does ask
for a measure of resting heart rate and
so based I assume on some parameters
that relate to your habitual fitness
level and also your resting heart rate
those are probably two of the the main
drivers obviously I don't know
everything that goes into the algorithm
but that's typically what it's what it's
based on and I think probably these
online calculators the greatest benefit
even if there's an absolute error in the
number you would hope that it's a fairly
reproducible number so if if you do some
training and your resting heart rate is
lower Purdue presumably the the value
that would predict for your vo2 max
would would be higher but that's what
it's based on but as you say having a
vo2 max test measure directly is the
gold standard but there's also some
reasonable ways to estimate it based on
running speed over a set distance or
heart rate response to submaximal
exercise so I think it's fairly easy and
you know maybe we can leave folks with
some tips on the online aspect of this
interview with ways that they can get a
sense of their their fitness on their
own for sure
and you you said something I want to
underscore for folks because it's so
important many of these tools
one could argue even most of these tools
are not they're not a hundred percent
accurate in an absolute sense but as
long as they're in as long as they are
consistently inaccurate you can trend
properly right which is which is also
why it's so important if people are
trying to gauge body fat which is
notoriously error-prone for a host of
different reasons that they're using the
same tool and if they're using a
practitioner or some type of clinician
they're using the same practitioner
clinician so that at the very least
they're comparing apples to apples so
they can trend properly and look at how
an intervention like the training that
we'll be talking about I'm sure effects
the numbers that they're putting in
agree that's an excellent point you know
if you're looking at something like
bioelectrical impedance for example to
measure body fat percentage there's some
concerns around the absolute validity of
that test but I think when you use the
same test repeatedly over time it gives
you a good sense as you say to know
whether you're trending positive or
trending negative and that's the
important thing when did you do your
first studies or begin researching
sprints or interval training and what
catalyzed that it would be around 2003
2004 and believe it or not it stemmed in
large part from that course that we
mentioned at the outset of the interview
so I've taught this course integrative
physiology of human performance for for
quite a while now I think this is the
16th or 17th version of it and it does
go back to that idea of students were
interested in the training programs of
elite athletes and they were often
surprised by the fact that elite
endurance athletes through the course of
history surprisingly used interval
training either because they were quite
time limited or because they really
wanted to push their overall training
volumes or often it related to the the
notion of time efficiency you know that
one of the classic examples would be
Roger Bannister when he was training for
the
on the four-minute mile he was a very
busy medical student who had about a
half an hour at lunch to train and he
would repeat short intervals around the
track at a very high tempo so that led
to my initial interest in the topic and
then that led to some very simple early
designs around some studies around
either how low can you go
so you know a theme through my research
has been time efficiency of exercise and
definitely this idea of how low can you
go both in terms of boosting performance
if you're an athlete but increasingly in
terms of boosting health if you're an
average individual or someone with
metabolic syndrome or type-2 diabetes
for example you've had a number of
influences and I'd love to just place
these on a timeline as well because it's
such a fascinating set of research that
you have and how it has evolved over
time could you talk a little bit about
Richard Metcalf and in tabata yes of
course and at a point I would make is
that you know we don't know what we
don't know and so when I first got into
this field obviously we're very
interested in the topic but over time
I've definitely developed an
appreciation both for the scientific
history of interval training which goes
back to at least the late 1950s and
probably before that and the athletic
history which certainly dates to the
turn of the century but we were
influenced of course by some of the work
that Tabata had done you know he's a
classic paper from the mid 1990s that
led to Tabata style training and they
were of course we're not working in a
vacuum we've been influenced by other
researchers as well you mentioned
Richard Metcalfe and there's some other
researchers working with him in in the
UK who have had this similar type
question and that's this idea of how low
can you go and so Richard and some
others had done a scientific study where
they were looking at just two bursts of
interval training lasting only 15 to 20
seconds and showing that if subjects did
that a couple of times a week for six
weeks they could boost their vo2 Max and
so that was influential in terms of our
our
research and it led the design of what
we call the the quote unquote one minute
protocol or the one minute workout which
of course is the teaser headline it's
not really a minute start to finish when
you build in recovery and a short warm
up and cool down but it's all variations
on this theme that short hard bursts of
exercise can be extremely effective and
extremely time efficient in order to
boost performance and boost health and
we're gonna talk plenty about that I
want to come back to Tabata for a second
and ask you a question or a few
questions that were sent to me by a
friend of mine who's a an MD very
accomplished athlete and a huge fan of
interval training his first question and
maybe before we actually get to this
question could you define for people
what the Tabata protocol is yeah so the
classic Tabata protocol is eight repeats
of a cycle that involves 20 seconds of
effort and 10 seconds of rest so you
repeat that eight times and so start to
finish the workout is four minutes in
duration the original classic study that
was described was done on a bicycle so
bicycle exercise at an intensity of
around a hundred and seventy percent of
vo2 Max and people might say well if vo2
Max is max how can you go at a hundred
and seventy percent of that but it it
goes to the workload setting that you
would have on the bike so you might have
a workload for example of 300 Watts and
that's sufficient to elicit your vo2 max
but you could work at above that value
or 170 percent of that value for very
short periods of time but that's the
classic Tabata protocol and as I say it
was described on a bike although over
time it's probably more well-known to
most your listeners for more calisthenic
type style training burpees mountain
climbers air squats things like that
although the original protocol was
described up for a bicycle thank you and
the first question from a friend of mine
is is Tabata especially magical or have
the date have been over-interpreted
and keep in mind this is someone who is
part of the choir so to speak not
necessarily for Tabata but it's it's
it's been so widely discussed and so
widely I would imagine maybe
misinterpreted but is it is is the
Tabata protocol particularly magical or
have the data been over interpreted in
any way I don't think it's particularly
magical
I think Tabata is an example and
obviously a well-known example of the
concept that we were talking about and
that's this idea that short hard bursts
of exercise can be extremely effective
and so the original Tabata protocol the
main outcome measure was maximal aerobic
capacity or vo2 max and so Tabata showed
that short hard intervals on the bike as
we've described could be effective for
boosting vo2 max they didn't perform
muscle biopsies for example there wasn't
a lot of underlying physiological
measurements performed and I think
that's one of the additions to the
scientific literature of our work as
well as other researchers that they've
looked more mechanistically at what's
happening so for example we've been very
interested in short hard bursts of
exercise improving muscle health and
boosting things like mitochondrial
content in your muscles I think there
has been some overstatement in the fact
that Tabata is viewed with almost these
magical properties when it comes to
Tabata style training that I think most
people think of and thats bodyweight
style intervals
there's surprisingly less scientific
evidence that speaks directly to that
there's really only a handful of studies
that have looked at Tabata style body
weights and the effect on strength and
maximal aerobic capacity that being said
those studies have shown that it's a
very efficient way to train and so I I
think of it as a very good middle ground
you know the benefit in aerobic capacity
that you'll see might not be as great as
if you do large amounts of other
traditional endurance style training and
obviously the improvements that you have
in strength and hypertrophy are not
going to be like heavy resistance
exercise but again from a time
efficiency aspect body white style
intervals are there's
there there there provide a lot of bang
for your buck
and I think that also perhaps what
contributes to the smaller data set when
it relates to the body weight training
is that it's it's what strike me as
harder to measure in some respects right
if you're if you're using wattage you
can go from a hundred percent to a
hundred and seventy percent with a lot
more precision if you want to manage
that and really look at how the inputs
affect the outputs or how different
degrees of say super maximal effort
affects the outcomes but it would strike
me is a lot more difficult when you're
doing calisthenic type exercise in a
research setting at least you make a
really good point people ask us all the
time why is most of our research done on
the bike and how does it translate to
other types of activity and the main
reason is as you say we can quantify
things like work and power very
accurately and so that enhances the
scientific rigor of the study in terms
of our ability to control the stimulus
and then we're obviously often looking
at very specific physiological markers
that require us to perform invasive
measurements whereas if you're just
doing a set of burpees for example it's
a little bit more challenging to
precisely control the stimulus and so
that sometimes can go to the impact of
the study if you will and there I'm
talking the scientific impact cuz I have
to worry about things like where I
publish my papers and journal impact
factors and things like that but
ironically you know a lot of the public
doesn't care about an impact factor they
just want to know if I do this type of
training will that benefit me so there's
sometimes an inherent tension there
between the scientific and impact of a
work and really the the translate
ability of the work and answering
questions that people actually want to
know about yeah and the let's talk about
the scientific a little bit more because
it's I think it's easy for people who
have had no experience in academia or
research to talk about people in their
ivory towers and doing all this
theoretical this that the other thing
that doesn't translate without
recognizing the importance of
properly executed scientific method if
you want your data to be persuasive and
defensible right which you really need
first and foremost before you can
prescribe some type of variant to be
applied in the real world with some
degree of confidence so but the that's
not the question I'm gonna ask her
related to the question what I wanted to
ask you is in your own research as it
relates to interval training what was
the first study that surprised you in
some way because of your forming
hypotheses beforehand right you have a
lot of experiences physiologies and
exposure to interval training was there
a particular study that that sticks out
for you
as surprising even to you yes our first
study actually was one of our most
impactful and I was I was influenced by
a number of scientific papers of course
but one of the most interesting for me
was this group in Europe had taken two
groups of subjects and they applied the
same training stimulus to both groups
and the training stimulus involved 14
consecutive days of hard workouts one
group did them every day consecutively
for two weeks and one group did them
every couple of days over a period of
six weeks so the the training stimulus
is the same and really all it was
different was obviously one group was
getting recovery days at the end of the
study period the physiological
adaptations between the groups were
virtually identical so measuring
specific changes in their muscles or how
much an enzyme level went up but the
performance was only better in the group
that got recovery days and I'm sure your
audience is listening going well duh
that sort of makes sense but it hammered
home for me this idea that recovery was
important and so our first question was
well what if we had people only do two
weeks of interval training or the period
of measurement is only over two weeks
but we give them those recovery days and
so that led to our initial study where
we had people do six sessions of
interval training over 14 days and what
we measured in that study that two major
outcomes were was endurance performance
so basically time to fatigue on an
exercise bike how long can you ride a
bike until you're exhausted and the
amazing thing was that subjects
endurance capacity increased by a
hundred percent on average so basically
you could double endurance capacity with
six sessions of interval exercise and
we're talking this short hard sprint
type exercise so the type of intervals
that people were doing only required
them to do two to three minutes of very
heavy exercise every couple of days and
we back that up with some physiological
markers we took biopsies from the
subjects legs and we measured an
important enzyme that relates to how
well the body uses oxygen to burn fuels
to produce energy and we saw that that
enzyme increased by about 35% if I
recall what was that enzyme it's an
enzyme called citrate synthase it's
arguably the most commonly measured
enzyme and exercise physiology it's a
marker of the Krebs cycle or the TCA
cycle and it correlates quite well with
the overall amount of mitochondria that
a subject has in in their legs so again
people have a pretty good sense of
cardio health and what that means the
ability of your heart to pump blood and
deliver oxygen citrate synthase or
mitochondrial content is a pretty good
marker of muscle health how well your
body can utilize the oxygen that gets
delivered to produce energy it's also
important for things like predicting
your risk for diabetes if you have a
higher citrate synthase content in your
muscles your risk for developing type 2
diabetes tends to be lower but the short
answer is that when people did these six
sessions of intervals over two weeks
they doubled their endurance capacity
and they markedly increase the amount of
this enzyme in their muscle and that's
where I really sat back and went wow
maybe we're onto something here and you
know as a cautious scientist the first
thing to do is to tell your grads
make all those measurements again show
me that the data are reproducible
because when we first published that
study there I don't wanna say there was
off to opposition but there was
skepticism to be sure and certainly we
were happy as more research studies were
conducted both in our own lab and around
the world verifying some of these
initial findings quick question on
methodology because I've always been
very curious about this I was a I've
been a test subject in a number of
different experiments that were not
designed by the the amateur professional
dilettante which I know is the
contradiction in terms
Tim Ferriss but actual legitimate
scientists and at places like Stanford I
was part of a body cooling experiment or
the intervention was body cooling using
a vacuum and a glove of all things
looking at heat exhaustion and marching
in saunas it was it was a disaster in
terms of just subjective experiences
pretty miserable but I've I've been a
participant in a number of different
labs and I'd be I'd love to know in your
lab what is the right way to identify
when someone on a bike has ridden to
exhaustion had you defined that because
of course if you have rats a lot easier
right you put and this is not something
I've personally done but I know they'll
do swim tests and to exhaustion means
the rat basically doesn't necessarily
drown because it probably doesn't die
and or it might but they put them in a
bucket let's go swim until they can't
swim anymore not as easy to get
approvals to do that with say college
students or or other human subjects so
how do you how do you define and
determine when someone has written to
exhaustion so we would measure for
define fatigue as a point at which
subjects are unable to maintain the
power output so you're going to have you
ride at 200 watts you could ride at 200
watts for a certain period of time and
then literally you get to the point
where you're unable to turn the pedals
and so what typically happens is you'll
see cadence fall so if someone's
maintaining 90 revolutions per minute
obviously the force per revolution or
the load per revolution will seem a
little bit lighter than if they're only
riding at 50 rpm so we use bikes that
are electrically braked cycle ergometer
x' so that we know regardless of how
fast the subject is turning the pedals
the workload is the same at 200 watts
and so as people approach fatigue or
exhaustion they literally can't turn the
pedals and for us it's usually defined
as there are rpms falling below 40
because that's where the manufacturers
will guarantee the workload setting on
the bike but what you find is they tend
to hit exhaustion pretty quickly so it's
not very hard to figure out when they
have to literally stop and sometimes
we'll use time to exhaustion test but as
a colleague mark Hargreaves will say
there's no Olympic events in time to
exhaustion I typically that be a
riveting spectator sport though exactly
and so most athletic events are you need
to cover a set distance as fast as
possible and that's why certainly more
recently but often in our studies will
use time trials as well where subjects
they'll have to complete a set amount of
work and we'll say think of this as a 10
kilometer bicycle race and as they go
through they're able to see elapsed
distance or work done so they can work
towards a goal and again it more CIMMYT
it more closely simulates normal
athletic competition see you mentioned
citrate synthase which if that's I
remember having a biopsy done in South
Africa at Tim Noakes facility it has
some really interesting thoughts on
central governor's and so on but I
remember coming in to look at the
results and I'm effectively below the
Homer Simpson acid entry line in my
citrate synthase in my in my I think it
was the vastus lateralis or maybe it was
a medialis that took it from in the
quadricep uh but could you talk to which
is obviously something I should I should
address but could you please describe
what mitochondria are and why they're
important and then how say citrus and
they
relates to mitochondria if at all sure
so mitochondria are often termed the
powerhouse of the cell they're the
specialized organelles or a component of
a cell where fuel is converted into
energy using oxygen so obviously the
internal processes there are quite
complex but essentially mitochondria
suck in fuels like glucose and fats and
use oxygen to combust to burn those
fuels in order to produce cellular
energy in the form of ATP how if people
might be you know they may have taken a
biology course or read a textbook you
often see mitochondria presented as
these being shaped organelles in a
two-dimensional image on on the page and
certainly what we know now are they're
much more like complex networks that run
throughout in this case the the muscle
cells so they're very impressive
structures and so when you have
mitochondrial biogenesis or an increase
in mitochondria it's it's a bit like an
expansion of this intra cellular network
so you know if you imagine a garden hose
it would it be a bit like the garden
hose growing more tentacles in this
network expanding throughout the the
muscle cell mitochondria contain many
different enzymes that are involved in
this process called oxidative
phosphorylation which is that just
another name for that process of
producing cellular energy and so a
common enzyme that's relatively
convenient to measure because if you're
going to try and assess mitochondria you
need some some different markers and
some of these markers are better than
others but citrate synthase is a
specific enzyme located inside the
mitochondrial compartment or network and
that enzyme is involved in oxidative
phosphorylation and so the the
measurement of the content of that
enzyme provides a pretty good index or
marker of the overall mitochondrial
network capacity got it so when you are
tracking say improvement
and mitochondrial improvement per se
through high-intensity interval training
is citrate synthase the primary marker
that you're tracking or are there other
markers or for that matter graphic
representations of density of
mitochondria or something else that
you're looking at closely we almost
always measure citrate synthase because
again it's a it's a fairly robust and
commonly accepted marker of
mitochondrial content ideally though
will include other measurements as well
either performed in my laboratory or
through collaborations with some other
scientists both at McMaster and
elsewhere so typically we'll measure a
suite of enzymes
so not just citrate synthase we'll
measure a couple of other ones as well
sometimes we'll measure what's known as
mitochondrial respiration so this is
just another way to demonstrate how much
oxygen the mitochondria is using and you
can see for example an increase in
mitochondrial respiration rate after
training and sometimes we'll measure
molecular compounds that are our signals
that mitochondrial biogenesis is taking
place or in the process of taking place
so some of our studies for example are
acute exercise studies we'll have
someone do a single bout of exercise and
then we'll take biopsies in recovery and
we'll say okay is the mitochondrial bio
synthesis pathways are are these
activated and we'll measure certain
proteins that are representative of that
other times we'll do training studies
and that's where we would commonly
measure citrate synthase in some of
these other markers to show that these
enzymes had in fact either the maximal
activity where the content had increased
pulling to the training protocol so to
jump to protocol or I guess go out to
sort of 30,000 foot view a little bit I
remember doing some reading and prep for
this conversation and finding a Baggesen
assertion I haven't looked at the data
behind it but that even interval walking
in many respects could be considered
more
I guess effective then say steady-state
walking for catalyzing health
improvements why is that why why does
that why does this type of oscillation
in effort have profound effects and why
does it apply to something at a say low
level of input or output rather like
walking all the way up to sprinting what
what does interval training do to the
body it's a great question we can get
into some of the details there and it's
certainly something that keeps me
interested as a scientist you know
trying to figure out the mechanisms at
play here your question also raises
another point that's important I think
to note and that's that interval
training is almost infinitely variable
and so people have this idea in their
head of what interval training looks
like but for some individuals interval
training is just if you're only exercise
is walking around a block picking up the
pace for a couple of light posts and
then backing off and that's gentle
interval training is just interval
walking as you alluded to and I would
often give that example for more
deconditioned individuals that's what
interval training looks like for them
but there is certainly scientific
evidence to suggest that that type of
training so just fairing up the pace a
little bit is going to be more
beneficial than continuous steady-state
walking just to say one quick example
there's a study out of Denmark that was
looking at individuals with type 2
diabetes and they divided them into one
of two groups one that did steady-state
walking that elicited about 66% of their
maximal heart rate and the other group
did interval walking that the overall
average intensity was the same 66% but
they would just pick up the pace a
little bit maybe go to 70% and then
maybe back off a little bit and after
several months of training what they
found was that the interval walkers even
though the total amount of exercise done
was the same their fitness was improved
to a greater extent they had lost more
body fat and their body composition was
superior and their average blood sugar
had decreased by a greater amount even
though the total
amount of exercise that was done was the
same and so sorry that I was just gonna
say that goes to the question of why so
the end the the lowered fasting glucose
being reflective of the greater ability
to utilize glucose by say mitochondria
or muscle in general is that the yes
also a greater ability to to store it as
well so a question is always well if you
lower your blood glucose where does that
glucose go part of it is probably an
enhanced ability to store the glucose
inside skeletal muscle for example as as
stored glycogen we know that training
exercise training almost of any sort
increases the muscles ability to take up
glucose so glucose transport capacity
increases and that also is a function of
exercise intensity so when we've done
some of our interval training studies
and people with type 2 diabetes we see
that there can be marked increases in
glucose transport capacity and the
amount of glucose transporters that
these subjects have in their muscles
following a period of training see
you've you've done many different
I'm sure personally variations of
interval training youth you've studied
you've design studies and imposed said
regimens on many different subjects if
you had for instance a I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you a profile and this is
this is that if yourself interest so
let's just say you had a former
competitive athlete with more than a few
injuries but nothing hugely debilitating
maybe a sprained ACL in the past some
some issues with plantar fasciitis etc
so not generally going to be looking for
any type of sprinting on safe flat
ground where I'm gonna might risk
tearing a hamstring at the end range or
something like that just happened before
I who's who's willing to put in some
time but not too much if it makes sense
I'm not looking for the
absolute bare minimum that will elicit a
change I'm looking for the sort of
minimal effective dose that I might
experiment with which would produce
hopefully a profound change of some type
or improvement over my baseline which is
pretty shitty to be quite frank I'm not
an endurance athlete by any stretch of
the imagination in my vo2 Max's is quite
poor what might what might a a protocol
look like for me to start with for I'd
probably probe that individual or ask
you for yeah you can ask me you know
what are the goals here you know are the
goals boosting cardio spirit or fitness
for health is it more from a performance
element so I guess what is the goal of
the exercise training program is it you
know is it general maintenance of of
health and fitness in a very busy life
and trying to fit that in as best you
can for me it would be in a generalized
sense improving in endurance and Veeam
and vo2 max not for any particular
sporting event but for general
application to say I might go to high I
went to high altitude in Colorado last
year for five or six days and it was I
would say 10 to 12 hours of very high
intensity hiking per day often at a very
steep incline so for generalized cardio
respiratory and muscular endurance a and
these are not in order of priority then
and be for extensible of life extension
purposes that's it I've always been more
of a power athlete or strength athlete
than an endurance athlete and it would
be it would be fun may not be the right
word but it would be worthwhile I think
for me to establish a baseline and then
attempt to improve the markers that
matter and watch that over time I would
say then if you could give me three 25
minute blocks of time a week so let's
say we're gonna design this to be a 25
five-minute session of training that you
do three times a week you will have a
very short warm-up in a very short
cooldown so let's assume we have 20
minutes to work with where you're
actually putting out some effort and I
will you not to drink colleges but I'd
love to hear what you'd recommend for
warm up and cool down also the the warm
up and cool downs would be quite short
so let let's describe the protocol here
what I'd have you do come in and do two
minutes on the bike at a low workload
setting to warm up I'm saying the bike
because you know you alluded to maybe
some some joint or connective tissue
issues there with the hamstring or you
know many people have ageing knees I put
myself in that category so all of my
interval training or almost all of it is
on a bike but the warm-up would be brief
and it would be perhaps 75 watts so a
low workload setting and then we'd get
right into the the hard work and now I
you know from the outset let me say we
would always recommend that someone see
their physician before they begin or
change an exercise routine so let's get
that out of the way but in our studies
even in the individuals with type 2
diabetes metabolic syndrome we typically
keep the warm ups and the cool downs
quite short because otherwise it
detracts from the time efficiency so in
almost all of our studies the standard
warmup is two minutes and a standard
cool-down is three minutes and that's
typically just very light cycling
unloaded cycling or maybe at a very low
workload setting as I say around 50
watts or so I'm gonna ask a nitty-gritty
question and I apologize what type of
bikes do you use for these studies in
terms of make and model we use a variety
of bikes at home in my basement I have a
life cycle a 95 C life cycle that I use
inside of our research laboratory we
have a couple of different bikes we have
low D xcalibur sports which are one of
the Cadillac versions on the market what
was that first name with the first word
in Lodi LOD II it's a company out of out
of Germany and so there they would be a
gold standard ergometer that a lot of
exercise physiology labs
would have we've also used racer made
bikes in the lab and and we've also
recently purchased a couple of Kettler
bikes which are certainly cheaper than
then lodi's but they're electrically
braked durometer so they are quite
accurate in terms of holding the power
output that's set so we use a couple of
different bikes but ya know those would
be the ones Sergeant interrupts so we've
we've gone through the the two minute
warm-up with say potentially 75 watts
right and then I would have you do a
series of intervals hard intervals that
lasts between three and five minutes so
let's say if you have 20 minutes I would
have you do three to start the pick one
will do three five-minute efforts with a
little bit of recovery in between so I'd
have to check my math there but you know
so that would basically be fifteen
minutes of hard riding within that 20
minute period and so I would structure
initially the intervals to last between
three and five minutes and so this you
know we would adjust the workload
setting appropriately so that let's say
you're doing three minute repeats you
don't want to go much more at the end of
those three minutes but if I give you a
period of recovery you're able to repeat
the three minutes a couple of times or
if it was a five minute interval it
would be the same thing so these would
we would set the workload so the
intervals are challenging and you're
almost ready to give up where you're
getting towards the end of the three or
five minute interval but then we give
you a little bit of break and you do it
again and why I say the three to five
minute intervals is if you look at the
the literature and there's been a number
of review articles and meta analyses
that have been conducted and just
through practical experience with
coaches and athletes many would
recommend that that repeated intervals
of three to five minutes in duration is
going to provide the most effective
stimulus for boosting vo2 max so that's
I think where I'd start but we would
vary it up as well another common
protocol is what we call the ten by one
so
one minute of hard exercise with one
minute of recovery and you repeat that
10 times so there's no magical or best
formula but it probably start with those
three to five minutes because based on
the literature that would be my best
guess for boosting your vo2 Max and
during the interval and of course you
would
calibrate this as you're working with
the subject but what type of wattage how
would you determine the setting to start
with yes so again if it was you ideally
how we do this in the lab for example if
we had the opportunity to do it in
advance we would have you come into the
lab and perform a vo2 max test so
typically in our lab we use ramped vo2
max tests so we have a very standard
protocol if we increase the workload
setting one one watt every two seconds
and so basically what it feels like is
you're climbing up a hill that gets
steeper and steeper and steeper starts
out pretty easy and then it you know the
workload catches up on you over time and
why we like the ramp test is again at
some point you're gonna hit exhaustion
or fatigue and I could say ah Tim your
peak power output was 388 watts or 452
watts and then we would begin by taking
percentages of that peak power output
out of that peak power output becomes
your hundred percent exactly and so we
know from experience there's always a
little bit of trial and error but if
you're you know a relatively fit
individual you might be able to do
repeats at 90 or 95 percent of that peak
power output and hold that for a couple
of minutes whereas some other
individuals especially those who are
very key deconditioned if I put them at
sixty percent of peak power output they
would struggle to last for one minute so
that's where knowing a little bit about
the typical training background of the
individual comes into play but there's
always a little bit of trial and error
there the other way that we could do it
if we didn't have access to that vo2 max
test in advance is say okay we want
you on these ten by one intervals
ideally to get to 85 or 90 percent of
your maximum heart rate during every
interval and then you can adjust the
workload setting in a corresponding
manner so we can either do it very
objectively based on wattage or we can
do it more subjectively
based on heart rate responses or even
ratings of perceived exertion got it no
that makes sense and the ten by one that
is ten pairs of one one-minute hard one
minute easy effectively so you have ten
sets per se of single minute hard
interspersed with so it's a total of 20
minutes correct and no again we we've
used that protocol extensively in our in
our research we didn't design it others
and again this is where I as I learned
more about the scientific literature
this was a very common protocol used in
Germany in the mid 80s on individuals in
cardiac rehabilitation settings so
that's a protocol that I think has wide
applicability we've used it on
individuals with type 2 diabetes my
colleagues and other individuals have
applied at individuals with
cardiovascular disease in a cardiac
rehabilitation setting and we've used it
on very fit young men and again that's
where we scale the percentage of PPO but
in all of those individuals it's been
effective to boost their health outcomes
and boost their maximal aerobic capacity
as well PPO not to be confused with HMO
and PPO and healthcare in the u.s.
that's the peak power output correct
okay can the how do you determine which
of say just for the sake of illustration
the three to five minute intervals times
three versus the ten by one which
subject to apply one of these protocols
to probably the deconditioned
individuals we would start with shorter
more frequent repeats and that's you
know one of the reasons I think the
three of the five minutes is so
effective for boosting vo2 max is
challenging to maintain a relatively
high workload for a period of time of
you know three to five minutes or so
that's that's very challenging in the
way that you know even the energy
systems in the body are utilized to
produce energy to sustain that is is
different and so I think the more
deconditioned the individual the more
effective protocols are the more
tolerable programs for those individuals
involve more frequent repeats that lasts
a shorter period of time and then of
course the progression is either
increasing the workload in and keeping
the protocol the same or if you play
this out what you basically do is
increase the work interval decrease the
recovery interval until at some point
that individual might be to able to
sustain 20 minutes of continuous
exercise at that pace and I suppose it
depends on of course as with many things
on your goals in the case of the goals
that I laid out before we chatted about
the protocol for the three to
five-minute intervals am I is it pure
rest in between those intervals or is it
easier cycling and why good question
ideally we want the recovery to be
active why is that sir oh well one of
the reasons is especially when you do
very hard exercise and then you
completely stop the risk of things like
fainting is is increased and and that's
because you can have a fall and blood
pressure when you stop after doing very
hard exercise and one of the reasons for
that is you have all of this
vasodilation or opening of the vessels
especially in the legs and you have a
pooling of blood in the lower
extremities and and so one of the
reasons people can faint after doing a
very vigorous pot of exercise when they
stop is they have this pooling in the
lower extremities they don't have the
venous return or pushing the blood back
to the heart and of course the blood
flow to the brain then transiently
decreases and so you faint so one is a
very practical reason and that's we want
to minimize the risk of fainting
especially in some of these
older or deconditioned individuals and
of course there the risk of fainting is
higher the more intense the the previous
exercise so that's a very practical
consideration also you want to just keep
the blood flowing a little bit you know
flush out some of these metabolites that
you've produced during the previous hard
bouts and so that's a consideration as
well so all things being equal active
recovery at a very low workload setting
is preferred but let's face it sometimes
these intervals are very very demanding
and people would rather just stop and
wait has ever done a Wingate test you
don't want to do much exercise in the
subsequent few periods of recovery you
you just want to stop and make me sit on
the ground so this is where there's that
trade-off between the proceeding
intensity and what the recovery might
look like and with the act of recovery
in this case so we're doing three sets
per se of three to five-minute intervals
let's just say five minutes if the
warm-up was at 75 watts
what would the wattage be on the act of
recovery now we would keep the active
recovery quite low as well so maybe even
going back to 75 or maybe a hundred
watts and it goes to then you don't want
to work too hard frankly in the recovery
periods because that's gonna take away
from your ability to put out the hard
efforts when you're really going for it
and so surprisingly you know your your
heart rate your oxygen uptake your
metabolism stays up very high during
these recovery periods even though the
actual workload setting can be can be
quite low but I think you know this
sawtooth pattern of going hard and then
taking a break and what I mean by taking
a break is keeping the recovery periods
active but the workload setting quite
low that's important because that allows
you to sort of refuel a little bit
recharge and be able to go hard in the
subsequent interval and how do you
decide on optimal I'll just call it rest
period even though we're talking active
recovery how do you decide on optimal
rest period and the reason I ask is for
instance in strength training if you're
looking for hypertrophy versus max
strength the rest periods can vary
dramatically you might have power
lifters who take five to ten minutes
between sets because they want to among
other things completely regenerate
creatine phosphate and so on how do you
determine the optimal rest period in
between these intervals it's a really
good question part of it is definitely
the metabolic considerations that you
alluded to there and so our subjects
able to restore their fossil creating
reserves within their muscle you know
generally speaking you can replace about
50% of your fossil create and within a
minute or so and and if you give four
minutes of recovery you can have near
complete restoration of fossil create
and that of course depends on a couple
of factors so part of the consideration
then is how much we want to allow the
individuals to to refuel but the
considerations that go into it and this
is where it comes back to that first
question that I asked you is what's an
individual's goals what time do they
have available for the workout because
you can allow ample periods of recovery
but especially if you're talking about
this notion of time efficient exercise
recovery periods can't can't be too long
so sometimes there's practical
considerations that we will take into
play there the other is the fundamental
question and we honestly don't have the
the answer to it and that's is it the
absolute power that drives the
adaptation or is it the relative stress
so to put that in another way I could
have people do intervals in a glycogen
depleted state or with full carbohydrate
restoration if their glycogen depleted
their power outputs are going to be
lower and they're gonna feel a lot
crappier
but the adaptations may in some respects
be a little bit better and so to put
that in the context of recovery if we
don't allow quote/unquote full recovery
the subsequent power output in the other
intervals is probably going to be lower
but the relative stress on the
individual is going to be higher and so
I think it comes back to the side
of variety variability is a good thing
because we're just hitting the body in
so many different ways and so for most
individuals there is no single best
program and and varying up the intervals
is is a good is a good strategy now
sorry just to add there obviously if
we're talking about an elite athlete and
we have a very specific coach who knows
this very specific athlete very well the
program is going to be very tailored and
very precisely figured out but more
generally speaking for an individual
even like yourself
I think bearing it up is a good approach
how frequently would you do the three
times five minutes effort work out how
how often meaning how many times per
week for instance or how many rest days
in between yeah so if and this is where
again it goes to the goals of the
individual but I would say these
intervals can be challenging clearly
mentally demanding and fatiguing so if
you're an individual that can tolerate
three sessions a week of this type of
training oh that's right three times
great because what you said but you know
if some other individuals can't can't
tolerate that so that's a consideration
as well what I will say is in the vast
majority of our studies we use a
protocol of three times per week in our
interval training for you know two six
or 12 weeks however long where the
study's gonna be and how does what we
just spoke about differ from the the the
namesake of the book which is the I
guess it's that the the one-minute
framing said to what what does that
refer to
so the the 1 minute workout which is the
the title of the book again it's it's
more of a tease or headline but it
specifically refers to a protocol that
we devised where the work involved is 3
20-second efforts so the total amount of
hard work during a workout if you will
is only one minute and that one minute
is broken up into three intervals that
20 seconds in duration now those
intervals are truly all-out exercise so
the workload setting on a bike is is
very very high and the pace I would use
to describe it is sprint from danger
pace or the case you would cycle at to
save your child from an oncoming car
this is very demanding exercise but what
we've demonstrated is is that type of
exercise can be extremely effective so
there's there's this clearly an
intensity duration trade-off the more
intense you're willing and able to work
the smaller the volume of exercise you
can get away with and still reap
benefits and it's not necessarily a
linear relationship it's almost an
exponential relationship so we're
talking about very short very very hard
efforts it's a surprisingly small dose
that you need in order to trigger a lot
of these adaptations and what type of
rest intervals do you have between these
20-second efforts so our because we were
you know we had done a number of these
studies with I mentioned Wingate
exercise before these thirty second
all-out efforts and then we would give
people a couple of a couple of minutes
of recovery and they'd repeat that four
or five times and we were sensitive to
the criticism the legitimate criticism
that well when you do these Wingate
training protocols they require about a
25 or 30 minute time commitment and so
yeah it's only two or three minutes of
exercise but it's a half hour of time
commitment so it's really not that time
efficient especially when we place it up
against the public health guidelines you
know the lower end of which is 75
minutes of vigorous exercise so we
wanted to come up with protocols that
were unquestionably time efficient and
so the standard one minute workout if
you will involves that two minute
warm-up and three minute cooldown so
that's five minutes of warm up and cool
down and then the hard work is a
20-second effort two minutes of recovery
the second 20-second effort another two
minutes of recovery and the third and
final 20-second sprint so you basically
have a five minute work period which
involves that one minute of hard
exercise so bottom line the
to call including warm up and cool down
is 10 minutes start to finish but within
that 10 minutes you're doing one minute
of very vigorous exercise in the in
subjects who are deconditioned or let's
just say on relatively untrained these
are not people who engage in any type of
regular let's just say leg dominance or
certainly like inclusive workouts right
these are not people who are going for
steep hikes three times a week or doing
any type of cycling or high reps squat
workouts anything like that
what type of improvements if you were to
take a huge sample of say a thousand
people what type of improvements would
you be looking for or expect on average
and in in what markers yeah so an first
point to make is that most of these
studies are relatively small and so that
idea of the large study with a thousand
people those are really some of the
studies that need to be done in interval
training research maybe we can get into
that later but in our studies to give
you one specific example we've compared
that one-minute protocol so this
involves one minute of exercise within a
10 minute time commitment and people do
that three times per week so the Sprint
group if you will is doing three minutes
of intense exercise within a 30 minute
time commitment each week we've compared
that protocol to a group who does
traditional cardio or the type of
continuous steady-state training that's
reflected in the public health
guidelines so the other group that we
compared them to was doing 55 zero
minutes of continuous exercise three
times per week so one group doing a
hundred and fifty minutes of traditional
moderate intensity cardio the other
group doing a 30-minute interval workout
but within that thirty minutes it was
only three minutes of very intense
exercise and in our most recent study
which was 12 weeks in duration the key
outcome measures were vo2 max as we
Debow we measured citrate synthase so a
marker of muscle health by taking
biopsies and we also measured what we
call their glycemic control or an index
of their insulin sensitivity basically
how well the body utilizes blood sugar
using a test called an intravenous
glucose tolerance test where you
literally infuse a bolus of sugar into
people's veins and you watch how that
sugar is handled over a period of time
it's a relatively robust marker of
insulin sensitivity and what we found
after 12 weeks is despite the huge
difference in time commitment all of the
markers improved by the same extent on
average in the two groups so the
improvement that we saw in vo2 Max was
19% on average over 12 weeks and that
was the same in the two groups we saw
about a 30% increase in that marker of
their mitochondrial content again quite
similar in the two groups if anything it
was a little bit higher in the interval
training group and the same for insulin
sensitivity the improvement that we saw
statistically was the same but it tended
to be a little bit higher in the
interval training group so a real
striking example I think of the potency
of interval exercise especially these
short all-out intervals to elicit
changes that we more traditionally
associate with public health guidelines
type research that's not to say at all
that we're criticizing the public health
guidelines it's just a striking
illustration of the fact that you can
elicit a lot of these traditional cardio
responses and muscle metabolic responses
and health responses using these short
very hard bursts of exercise and how do
you how would you suggest people begin a
program like this let's just say and and
maybe the answer is what we already
talked about whether it's the the three
to five-minute intervals and what Worthy
can you just remind me the read what
would you suggest as a starting rest
interval because we talked about the
benefits of potentially replenishing
phosphate creatine but then also the
potential improvement the magnitude of
change
if you're operating from a deficit per
se so where would you suggest I start
for instance if I'm doing these three
5-minute efforts how much rest would I
take in between with the EZ pedaling
yeah so if we were going to the the
twenty minutes that we were talking
about there you know if you built in
five minute intervals with two minutes
of easy pedaling or I guess would be two
and a half minutes of easy pedaling that
would add up to your 20 minutes so five
minutes two and a half minutes recovery
another five minutes two and a half
minutes recovery and the third and final
five minute effort if we were doing
three minute repeats you know you could
do a series of five by four so three
minute effort one minute of recovery and
repeat that five times and that would
add up to your 20 minutes so again I
think someone like yourself I would lean
maybe towards the shorter recovery
because you're already in in relatively
decent shape of course and so ideally
you want to do as much high intensity
work as you can within that 20 minute
time frame now if we were to move you to
the 1 minute workout of course you're
going all-out so the efforts would be
extremely demanding and the peak power
outputs that someone like you could
elicit are obviously going to be much
higher than someone who's not in as good
a shape or certainly someone who's more
deconditioned so there's a couple ways
to answer your your general question the
first is what will generally tell people
is just get out of your comfort zone and
so if you're new to intervals maybe
starting with the the gentle interval
walking approach or utilizing that
strategy of going hard for a couple of
minutes and then backing off for a
couple of minutes
that's a beginner interval workout and
it you know in the book we lay out some
examples we have 12 different workouts
that we lay out all based on science so
people would know that the the basics of
these workouts are grounded in good
science but we present them as providing
in individuals with some ideas and
different varieties of interval training
protocols that they might use depending
if they're just starting out depending
if they're a more highly trained
individual again providing some of the
science behind
and some ideas for for how to structure
it
what are outside of the certainly
starting with the first study you've
been innovating in this space and
experienced some blowback or criticism
or not even criticism maybe even
criticized even criticized but you
certainly get criticism but all the
skepticism what are outside of what
you've written in this book what are
things that you believe that other
people might think are crazy is there
anything else that comes to mind where
are you you're you disagree with
conventional thinking or conclusions as
they stand right now doesn't have to be
limited to physiology but certainly
could be in physiology no affair well it
you know I almost hesitate to say this a
little bit because I I'm sure might get
some blowback even even on this but you
know in some ways I see a move to
demonize traditional cardio if you will
or you will read things like traditional
modern intensity exercise is ineffective
or it has no place and you know I would
I disagree with that uh clearly I'm a
very I'm big on interval training I'm a
proponent of it I think it can be widely
applied and I think it can be extremely
beneficial for a lot of individuals and
so I think it's underutilized and it's
very effective but that's not to say
that there's no place for traditional
steady-state exercise and certainly it's
erroneous to suggest that that type of
training is completely irrelevant or it
won't provide you with with any benefits
so I guess that would be one example
where I might take exception to some
advice common advice that I will often
often hear a few other questions related
may be it may be in a related problem
actually I'm gonna I'm gonna jump into
the callisthenic components a you I've
read that you've said before if you had
to choose one exercise you would choose
the Burpee
so I'm a big fan of burpees I've done a
lot of burpees in my life from wrestling
and jiu-jitsu and so on Pookie's are a
nice variation of that as well with the
pull-up bar above you but I I wanted to
aid you still feel that way about
burpees and then B I've read that you in
resistance training and the resist
resistance training that you do you
train to failure but you'll do cycles so
you have three sets to failure B set
each exercise so be curious to know so a
do you still feel that way but the
burpees and then B why three sets to
failure as opposed to one or two I do
feel that way about the Burpee and you
know let's frame the question here and
the question that I received was what is
the single best exercise which really
means you know if you were only
restricted to one exercise what would
you do and why and obviously even the
it's hard to fathom the question but I
first would the Burpee because number
one it requires no specialized equipment
it's a bodyweight style movement so you
can do them anywhere number two it's
going to build both strength and cardio
spirit or fitness so if you do Burpee
sets obviously you're gonna have some
push-up motion in there you're gonna
have some leg strength development but
if you're doing Burpee sets and it goes
to the second part of your question I
guess why would you do three sets
because I think applying burpees in
interval manner and doing a couple of
sets of them allow you to keep the heart
rate up which is going to provide the
the cardiovascular training so the I
would stick with the burpees it's can be
done anywhere and if you do Burpee sets
it provides both a cardio respiratory
boost as well as a strength boost you
know it going and just say I think I
also said at the time when I was asked a
question I don't really see anyone ever
sticking with a burpee workout over time
because let's face it burpees suck
burpees are really hard to do but if I
can give a shout out to this individual
contacted me
his name's Josh spodek he lives in
Manhattan he's PhD in astrophysics he's
got an MBA and he contacted me to say
you know I read that piece in New York
Times and I sort of took it up as a
challenge and I've been doing burpies
every day for five years and you know
it's basically become his go-to exercise
and so clearly some individuals could
keep it as their as their sort of go to
exercise so good on you Josh I certainly
couldn't keep that up even though I said
it would be my go-to exercise
yeah burpees I wouldn't put them I
wouldn't give them a very high ranking
in the physical recreation category for
sure if I could just make a comment to
Tim it and it goes you know I just said
burpees suck they they heard this is
something around interval training where
there's definitely very visceral
reactions around the potential translate
ability and so my colleagues who are in
the exercise and health psychology area
who talk about things like mood affect
motivation long-term adherence there's a
real visceral debate going on right now
around the potential long-term translate
ability of interval training clearly I'm
someone who is in the camp of yes I
think this is very much a viable public
health strategy certain types of
interval training are highly suited for
for many different individuals and again
it goes back to this idea that people
think interval training only means
extreme style training but there's a
large segment or there's certainly an
opinion out there that this is not a
viable public health strategy at all I
happen to disagree with that because I
think the more menu options we can give
people to bet the more exercise choices
the better but this idea that you know
intervals can be an uncomfortable way to
train and that might turn people off
exercise that's certainly a sentiment in
some quarters how do you use if we were
looking at I mean at least as I think
about it the three legs of the stool for
a sustainable beneficial exercise
program if you have
at the top of the if you have at the top
if we're trying to look at a hierarchy
adherence like well will will the
subject actually perform this routine
over time and then you have
effectiveness is does it produce the
results desired in any shape or form and
then efficiency as we've talked about a
number of times time efficiency how do
you increase the longer term adherence
to interval training is it just a matter
of starting off very moderate and then
condition people over time both
psychologically and physically to the
sometimes uncomfortable stimulus is
there other aspects to program design
that you would encourage people to think
about so we took there's a chapter in
the book we talked about this is a
psychology of interval training and I
interviewed a couple of experts who
provide some tips even things like for
example you know starting out early in
the day avoiding comparisons rewarding
yourself giving yourself a little treat
after you know celebrating success don't
beat yourself up you know I I think some
people can get down on exercise if they
don't have a big block of time or their
for example unable to sustain a moderate
intensity jog for 45 minutes or so they
start to beat themselves up I think with
intervals you can do a short interval
and experience a sensation of success
hey hey I did that and you know going
back to the cardiac patients almost any
of these individuals as they go through
their life life is an interval exercise
for these individuals because just
moving around can be quite challenging
and so even just just to get around and
go through activities of daily living
they have to perform it in in an
interval manner so I think my answer is
there's certain types of interval
training that are suited for certain
types of individuals and we also know
that again I'm not a health psychologist
but when I talk to my colleagues who are
experts experts in this going back to
this idea of menu choices the more
options we can give people the better
and I think interval training offers as
we
talking about almost an infinite variety
of ways to structure the workouts where
you know there's only so many ways to
jump on a treadmill and jog at a
moderate pace for 45 minutes or an hour
you can what you can watch a lot of
different shows on Netflix while you're
doing it though the other thing is that
intervals I think provide a way to
structure exercise into your life rather
than having to fit your life around
exercise and so people talk about
Stealth interval workouts you know as
corny as it sounds taking the stairs
lots of us live in apartment buildings
or work in office towers
that's a stealth interval workout just
doing a couple of stair flights
throughout the day there's this concept
of exercise snacking and we're learning
that for example it might be better to
do three ten-minute boats of exercise
through the day rather than a single
structured 30-minute boat of continuous
exercise at least when it comes to
things like your blood sugar control
so the intervals are well suited for
this concept of of exercise snacking as
well mm-hmm
Marty a couple of Nan physiology quite
non physiology questions although they
they could end up producing answers that
have something to do with it what books
have you gifted the most to other people
yeah you know this this question I'm
gonna sound like a scientist here but
one of the books that I've given out a
lot is called the craft of scientific
writing it's certainly something that
I'm working on but you know when I've
gifted books it's often been either to a
colleague or definitely new
up-and-coming people in the discipline
of science and the way you write
scientifically is obviously different
from from other writing and if if you
want to write scientifically but in a
compelling way for for individuals to
try and translate the science into the
lay public for example that's really
what I try to do with the one minute
workout is boil the science down write
it in a compelling and accessible manner
and certainly I had tremendous
assistance from from a colleague
Christopher Shulgin who's just a
tremendous writer and
we know we're on the right spot where I
was happy from the scientific message
and Chris was happy with the writing or
at least the readability of the
accessibility of the writing style and
that's that's a real challenge of course
it's it's an art as much as it is a
science and so a book like the craft of
scientific writing helps provide some
some tips there because you know if
you're a scientist coming up you're
constantly writing you're writing grants
you're writing papers and you want to
convince people of the point that you're
making you don't want to bore them and
you want to do it in a compelling manner
what what are some of your or any
science writers or science books that
come to mind as good examples to you
that Olga Wandy comes to mind for me
checklist manifesto and and others
certainly do any any particular writers
or books come to mind that have a
scientific accuracy to them but other
than are compelling yeah I you know
obviously I have a ton of respect for
for someone like Gretchen Reynolds at
the New York Times she's obviously a big
proponent of mineral training she's just
have been a supporter of our work but
you know her her book the first 20
minutes I think provided a really good
example or it set a bar for us in terms
of trying to structure the one minute
workout where you're trying to boil the
science down present it in a compelling
manner there's a Canadian named Alex
Hutchinson who writes for our national
newspaper The Globe and Mail he has a
book which comes first cardio or weights
same thing where he's I think there's a
gift there in terms of boiling these
scientific complex science down into
compelling narratives that people can
can read and understand so that's you
know that's initially two names that
come to mind at least in terms of people
that are taking science taking
scientific studies and trying to boil it
down into accessible messages that
people can use in their everyday lives
so speaking of everyday life this this
one is not always the easiest question
but we're gonna we're gonna probably
wrap up on on this which is if you could
put
message short message on a gigantic
billboard and of course metaphorically
urge getting a message out to millions
of people
anything non-commercial what would you
put on that billboard and I don't want
to fail miserably on this last test cuz
because part of me is like oh my god
what would I have that's so compelling
to say that I'm gonna put it out there
on on a billboard but you know we were
talking earlier a little bit offline
just as a scientist getting out of your
comfort zone a little bit as a scientist
you're you tend to be so cautious right
you're like almost everything you say
our studies end with well we need more
research on this or you write a grant
and you're afraid to get out of your
comfort zone and certainly as I've gone
through the process of writing this this
book by collaborating with Chris Shogun
on on this book it was really a matter
of you know what we do have something to
say here and there there might be an you
know there there's an audience out there
that needs this because I would often
get questions around where can I go for
more information where can I learn more
about interval training for health and I
I really couldn't point to a specific
website or book that was out there and
so in some ways we tried to fill that
void with with the book and boiling it
down and so I guess going to the the
Billboard question it would really be a
matter of telling people like you know
not to steal something from night night
but just get out there and do it or you
know what if you don't have a 45-minute
block of time to work out that's okay
you know build intervals or build
exercise build movement into your life
because we really really need that and
you know you look at the profound
influences that that that could have in
terms of boosting health lowering health
care costs when I talk to my students
it's about where could all of that money
that were otherwise spending on on drugs
and pills go well we can use that
investments in other places to better
support people because you know I it's
almost like I'm stealing other people's
lying things here but this notion of
exercise is medicine it's absolutely
true exercises the best medicine has so
few side effects associated with it but
the benefit that
we can get from it is tremendous and I
think some people are afraid of exercise
or you know obviously the number one
sighted barrier for why people don't
exercise is lack of time or perceived
lack of time and people have it in their
heads it if I don't have this big block
of time to exercise it's not worth it or
they blow it off and so if there's a
message it's really no time efficiency
we understand is important but even if
you have a ten minute period of time in
the day get out there move intervals
provide an extremely effective way to
build time efficient exercise into your
day and of course the benefits of that
are profound don't think of it as you
need to exercise to lose weight and
that's what confers health as we've been
talking about there's a direct line
there between exercise boosting your
cardio spirit or e fitness lowering your
risk of dying lowering your risk of
developing many of these chronic
conditions I had an idea also that you
could use and I will I will not charge
my typical royalty for this it's one
minute disappointing in the bedroom
plenty plenty in the gym and you have
your Marty where can people learn more
about you find you the book say hello on
social media or whatever you would like
to mention sure I'm on Twitter Gabala em
at Gabala m the book will be published
by penguin Random House it will be out
on February 7th you can pre-order now
from all of the usual booksellers
fantastic any any parting words
otherwise that you'd like to request or
otherwise I think you probably hit it
and that letter last answer but anything
like else that you would like to to say
or request of the audience no I I guess
if I had to come up with something for
that billboard then maybe its life is an
interval workout you know maybe that's
the way to go maybe that's the name for
the next for know obviously I'm big on
exercise I really appreciate this
opportunity to talk to you a little bit
about that but
exercise is is fantastic and if we could
just get more people moving the enormous
impact and benefit that would have on on
public health agreed and personal health
which is what it starts with
in a sense Marty thank you so much for
the time I really appreciate it
and to everybody listening you can find
show notes links to everything we
discussed as per usual at 4:00 hour work
week comm forward slash podcasts you can
find links resources from every episode
including this one and until next time
thank you for listening hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I have used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you will thank me there are
a few different versions
I like the version that Neil narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time
second book is vagabonding by Rolf Potts
pio TTS which had a huge impact on my
life and formed the basis for a lot of
what would later become the 4-hour
workweek so go to audible.com for word
slash Tim and you can choose one of
these two books or any of many many
other options that could be books
magazines and much more as a listener of
the Tim Ferriss show you can also access
a free 30-day trial just go to
audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at audible.com
butwhere slash tim to start now and get
your free 30-day trial this episode is
brought to you by 99designs I've used
99designs for years for all sorts of
graphic design needs whether you need a
logo website book cover or anything else
99designs was created to make great
designs accessible to everyone and to
make the process of getting designs much
much easier so when I first started out
for instance testing prototype covers
and getting prototype covers for the
4-hour body
I want the contest drop that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something late night quick
turnaround well people in other time
zones other countries can also help you
solve that problem since then I've
worked with 99 designs on a separate
path or a different option and that is
the one to one project service so in a
number of cases and I'll give you one
example when I wanted to create the
cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate more my
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
something incredibly good really some of
the best illustrations I've ever seen
from using this one-to-one project
service with a handful of different
designers and illustrators it blew my
mind 99 designs makes this all very easy
and efficient so you can check out the
Tao of Seneca design
and other work that I and your fellow
listeners for that matter have done on
99designs at 99designs comm forward
slash Tim again that's 99designs
dot-com for slash Tim
[Applause]